こんにちははじめしゃちょーであのツイーター見てると愛して総選挙というものがあり
ましたってこの3名は点は指まずミスをミスを答えは皆さん愛せ総選挙どんなのか教え
て個組1万人がが事前投票アイス造成今日2018
簡単に言うとテレビで愛せどランキングみたいなのが月で決めたやつがあったんです
けどもう僕はあの本当にな
でも見えません今日はちょっとパズドラしてたんだよ twitter は何も見て
ないんですけど妄想相手総選挙っていう凄いのがあったってことだけ知ってるんで僕
保護の愛車大好き芸人となるとアイスト4ストは何は色々分かれてランキングっていう
のを食べなんだっけそのわかるんですよ相手総選挙の結果を
廊下家は出ないです
ブーブー言っロスジャパンをちゃんと
順位から6機はん
[音楽]
今まで知ってる人もいるかもしれないんですけど by 争点化だ
はいベスト10はプロ通算の
をそっとみんなゴメン紹介が遅れちまったここにいるこいつは俺の後輩健介
かつて俺の動画で運動会のヨーイドン版で起こされたかわいそうな奴な
みんなよろしくない
そうなベスト10は俺の中で中だなんか無いさぁ食べているパパ10位の味を知ること
から始めたい
そうが10位ですか1針好かれない人なんて
[音楽]
11尾根沿い次の世代9いきたいとおもいます10位
ドイツ
マフィーの母これが級以下ピザも美味しいけど現れた俺なんかが空き台がわかればいい
んだと思ってみるちょっと減って来られていた
まあまあください8アイソレうーんこれねちょっと頃のように
マジすかブドウ味が勝ちますねこれはブドウアゾ空だったバニラ遺族ログなまぁまぁ
まぁまぁまぁまぁ
それ
[音楽]
まぁこんななかったのを待って鳳美味しい
6本当よ焼い端からやるわねまだ羽毛
ガード0うん落合だろこのキャッチーなんですよ
分かった頬者のば恋愛 rr にょえけっニャイチョンしないんですよすごいそんな
暑いのが100均具合直裁ちねおいしいよねー
高級の味がするんですよねいただけます
[音楽]
うーん
奪いなぁ
[音楽]
[拍手]
第六いっぱいこれ6位ってこれ6切って嫌でも美味しいやでも not 場行って
もらったまあまあそういうことでありが d 組んだ6いいかまあけどこれおいしいん
ですけど何がすごいってね大ベース本当に値段の割には本当にめちゃくちゃ美味しい
malloc いたロッキー者の話というところでありますので食べます
3秒でん
いただけます
月に行きたいね
[音楽]
進んでないフェス5のものだが住んでそこから準備を始めてくださりました今買った
10位か6位みた感覚でだいたいみんなのなんかわかったんで
おおーー
遅いこれでまいりますおーわー
スーパーカップやっぱりグラミーしてるそうなんですよそれで俺が驚いたのはもうがい
ない数アキ子もいないんだよたーーーー犬だっておいた
ふぅあ
危ない俺は大田かな
普段から
高い大豆を食べているの
危うく見ればれるとして
オフという
ハーゲンダッツ気になるところではあると思うじゃないですか第11ハーゲンダッツの
クッキークリームなクッキーとクリームを敷いレストで握ればならなかったってことが
12があずきバー井村屋の
中妻がハーゲンダッツのパヴァーヌファー件ドゥ
[音楽]
アップが藪ないん
裏は普段から俺はハゲ立つのバニラとクッキークリームしか来ないから
ランクインした上位2つの判決はほぼれかかってんだよな
続けこの中から1位から5位よ僕が当てますゼロに豆情報なんだけども雪見大福は普段
冬しか売ってないんですよシーズンものナイスだったんですけども体型前シーズン
常にお水に置かれるようになりましたちょっと味見してもいいですけどジャイアント
食べないんだよねーずめっちゃうまいですよこれこれくんったらぱぷりこ富川うりゃー
カプリ効果やなんですよ今もう
ああああ者からじゃあねドジャーは開け x って書いてありません
[音楽]
家でも一番食ってる俺多分
ってことはスーパーとプロペラが1位かさてはあります
[音楽]
ん
他事務所のせいですよ
すごかったからな違うぞって他に星な理由解雇って香具師楽に来やすくまで
黄金お知らせよいやー有名なでも混ぜたあれば相談
女子違ってきちゃってるけど大丈夫3回よってミスっ
許して3回ミスター the 坊主にする8位
聞きましたが皆さんケースが3回ヴィッツちな
3回ミスったら今年の夏はアイス食べませんまち前って5ライフの桜でも中で f
減ってこれ絶対ベッドへ増えたりがぁあああああやー
できますえっと5位
山とコーン
うん
ん
せいかイエスです1
まずポットポリマーじぇ
ブーブああああああ
って描いてこれぞ1位からいきます1位が
[音楽]
スーパーカップの場合らー
うん
ん
正解です
英会
正解ウィンディクリエイター fuck サクセスいい
パープル2
mappy 世界多そう
まあまあよっぱ強かったかアイスの王としての使命を果たしられないって言ってもいい
ですよろしくてればいいけどやっぱなたが一番なのでやむずくなってきたなぁ
ちょっと攻めますね
ていますか
際アントンコーお前すごいな買ってはに
前とコーン旋回です攝津正会員制1回
曲水 s 美ああふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ今後ワークレーションニャー
いやーこれだってたあってたんだったよかったでも結局一度にはてたんですそう
iso さやよろしくすればいいですか
豪華が入ります
北
5位
があっ
ここらへんだと思うんだよなぁスーパーカップのチョコず一家
チョコモナカジャンボなんだよな5位
子供なんかじゃん2塩害でマジで後いったいしてるんですよ
パン時代少なくなんですよが時代少なくなるよ感じでなく3つ残ってる
卍 line ダラーだやだよねとなればもう堂々と確実に取れそうね使われていない
ラストチャンスですね井山スムーズにな
2月作った
第3位
雪見だいふく
car
[音楽]
ただもうも魔物ぼああああ